make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and today we return to our what-if
series and we're going to ask the
question what would happen if the
Phoenix force showed up in the DC
Universe now as most of you probably
know the Phoenix saga in the Dark
Phoenix saga are considered by most to
not only be one of the greatest x-men
stories of all time but one of the
greatest superhero stories of all time
and if you disagree with that statement
then you're wrong so if you don't know
what happens in the Phoenix and Dark
Phoenix saga is a cosmic entity known as
the Phoenix which serves as the
embodiment of all life that has ever
currently does and will ever exist
throughout the entire omniverse to be
honest shows up and chooses Jean Grey as
its host
now once Jean Grey becomes the Phoenix
she becomes vastly more powerful than
she had ever been before and while she
is able to harness that power for a
while
she's eventually corrupted and overtaken
by the Phoenix force and becomes the
Dark Phoenix and literally starts
travelling around the galaxy consuming
energy and annihilating entire solar
systems really it was only one entire
solar system but it was like billions of
people so I guess I kind of sucks now
there's a lot more to it than that but
that's basically the super abbreviated
version and I only tell it to give some
context to the story that we're going to
tell today which is basically a
retooling of the Dark Phoenix saga set
in the DC Universe so cue dramatic music
so the first thing we have to do is
figure out who would be the host of the
Phoenix force if it showed up in the DC
Universe and so if we look at why Jean
Grey was chosen as the host for the
Phoenix up until Chris Claremont took
over writing duties on the x-men Jean
Grey was essentially treated as somewhat
of an afterthought on the team but
Claremont sought to make the character a
more important piece of the overall
mythos of not only the x-men but Marvel
Comics as a whole and so Claremont said
that it was his and Dave Cockrum desire
to turn gene into the first cosmic
female superhero and so gene taking on
the Phoenix force was initially an
attempt to revitalize a character that
was really inconsequential at the time
and turned her into a major force within
DC Comics and so with that in mind if
the Phoenix force were to show up in the
DC Universe its host should be a
character that is sort of treading that
water without any real direction as to
where their story arc is actually going
and so as odd as it may sound I think
this reasoning leads us to choose Dick
Grayson as the logical choice for the
Phoenix force and the reason I say that
is that although Dick Grayson has much
more of a history than gene did when she
became the Dark Phoenix right now his
character really seems to lack a
direction especially since he was shot
by the KGB seized memories and then
changed his name to Rick Grayson a
change that Nightwing fans absolutely
hated and so this would be a way to
bring dick back to the forefront of the
DC Universe and would also allow us to
bring in both the bat family and the
team Titans into the story as Dick
Grayson has significant history with
both groups so our story would start
with the Phoenix force searching the
galaxy for hosts with an explanation of
what the Phoenix is as well as his
purpose to judge the universe and
destroy the parts of it that are
unworthy and recreate those portions in
his own image and so the Phoenix sets
its sights upon the DC prime earth and
in particular the man formerly known as
Robin and Nightwing now the Phoenix
would since dick Grayson's heroism but
her psychic probe would reveal a mind
fractured and in turmoil struggling to
remember his past as well as forge a
path into the future under his new
identity now believing that it can bring
clarity to dick Grayson's mind it
chooses him as a host and makes its way
to earth now when the Phoenix makes
contact with dicks mind it sends him
into a state of shock and ultimately he
enters a comatose state as it recovers
in the Batcave under the watchful eye of
his mentor Bruce Wayne Bruce realizes by
reading his vital signs that something
far beyond the ordinary has happened to
dick and his biology has been
fundamentally changed and so over the
next few days
Batman devotes himself to trying to
figure out what's going on with his
former sidekick but dick suddenly awakes
from his slumber now he insists that he
feels fine physically better than he
ever has and Batman insists that he stay
and recuperate but dick is determined to
resume life as normal and furthermore
once to once again take up the mantle of
Nightwing and begin fighting crime and
so Batman warns against this but dick
ignores him leaves the Batcave and
things seem to go back to normal for the
time being now all this changes when the
earth is invaded by Larfleeze the orange
lantern and as the only orange Lantern
in existence Larfleeze is able to
harness all the power of the orange
power battery which makes him extremely
powerful now driven by his insatiable
greed Larfleeze has come to earth to
claim it for his own and the Justice
League is battling him with everyone
they have but are unable to gain the
upper hand in that battle and so I
called has put out for reinforcements a
call which is answered by most of the
superheroes on earth including Nightwing
now under normal circumstances Nightwing
would be fairly useless against such a
powerful opponent but as the heroes
battle
swing unleashes a powerful energy blast
that instantly vaporizes marsuits much
to the shock of literally everyone who
sees it happen now following the battle
Nightwing meets with the Justice League
to talk about what happened and he
explains to them that since he woke up
from his coma he's been able to do
things that he couldn't have imagined
before
this causes a huge amount of concern for
basically everyone involved in the
conversation as none of them have
seemingly any idea of what caused this
monumental increase in Nightwing's power
level now as time goes on
Nightwing begins to learn to control his
new abilities and in the process becomes
the most powerful hero in the DC
Universe now villains that would have
previously been threats to the continued
existence of earth seemed to be no
challenge for Nightwing or the Phoenix
as he now calls himself however as
Phoenix becomes more powerful he also
becomes less like Dick Grayson that the
heroes of DC Universe have known for so
many years and so he becomes ruthless in
dealing with supervillains often killing
them rather than incapacitating them and
instead of feeling comforted that the
earth has a seemingly omnipotent new
protector the superhero community begins
to fear what might happen if the Phoenix
ever decided to turn on them knowing
that he would likely be completely
unstoppable and so all of this comes to
a head during an incident in Gotham City
where hundreds die at the hands of the
Joker who's released copious amounts of
his toxin into the city streets now
Phoenix steps in vaporizes the toxin to
remove it from the atmosphere and in a
move that surprises nobody at this point
he kills the Joker now this leads to an
altercation between Batman and his
former Protege where dick becomes
furious at Batman for not killing the
Joker sooner he becomes incensed at the
idea that Batman could have taken out
the Joker in so many other villains and
saved tons of lives by doing so but
instead allows them to keep escaping
from custody and going out and killing
even more people now Batman predictably
points out that he would be no better
than the villains if they ever resorted
to killing but dick isn't buying it he
continues to get increasingly angry and
delivers an energy blast to Batman that
knocks him unconscious but stops short
of killing him before leaving now
Phoenix is not seen again for months and
in his absence crime ramps up as
criminals believe the threat is
completely gone now his crime rates soar
across the globe Phoenix comes out of
self-imposed isolation and begins
raining down fire and brimstone on
metropolis now Superman flies to meet
him in the skies over the city and
demands
what he's doing saying this is it like
you dick I've known you for years I know
you care too much of other people to do
something like this I feel like that's
how Superman would talk but Phoenix
would in turn answer Dick Grayson is
gone the Phoenix is all that remains in
this body and soon will be all that
remains on this planet this planet these
people are too far gone Superman just
look at him I left to give them a choice
to show me that they were worthy of
existing and look at all of them
committing more heinous acts than ever
before and you Batman the Justice League
all of you supposed heroes don't have
the courage to do what needs to be done
to stop them and so if you will not then
I will I will burn all of this down and
I will remake it all anew now obviously
Superman's not going to stand aside and
let this happen so he puts out a call to
the rest of the Justice League and
engages the Phoenix in battle knowing
that he cannot win and deep down knowing
the rest of the Justice League will
almost assuredly perish as well
now when the rest of the Justice League
shows up these go pretty much exactly as
you would expect meaning that they are
all getting completely obliterated by
the now Dark Phoenix on the ground
Batman sends out a message that the time
has come to execute their plan and on
the other end of the message we see
Raven one of dicks former teammates on
the Teen Titans and we learn here that
of course Batman has developed a plan
because what would a major event be
without Batman devising a plan to save
the day but we end up learning that
while dick was in a coma
Batman took a sample of his blood and
has been learning what he can about the
Phoenix force now knowing that there's
no way to pose an external threat to the
immense power of the Phoenix he decides
that the only way to defeat it will be
from within but to do that he needs a
telepath capable of reaching dicks mind
through the interference of the Phoenix
and so he ended up reaching out to Raven
now when Raven and the rest of the team
Titans arrived they find a pretty grim
scene right like Superman Shazam Wonder
Woman members of the Green Lantern Corps
have all taken to the sky and been
repelled by the Dark Phoenix but their
efforts are all proving to be futile now
they also find that members of the bat
family have also arrived including
Barbara Gordon Tim Drake and Damian
Wayne now as Dark Phoenix continues the
battle Raven makes telepathic contact
with him and probes his mind searching
for any sign of her friend Dick Grayson
inside and so the Phoenix force tries
it's best to repel Raven from dicks mind
but her resolve is too strong and she
finally makes contact with Dick Grayson
now in
moment dick racing would chime in and
say I can't find it Raven is too strong
and my mind hasn't been hold for a long
time that's why it was able to take over
I was simply too weak to fight and a
different voice besides Raven would
respond and say you're not weak dick you
never have been and this voice would of
course belong to Barbara who's been
telepathically linked to Dick Grayson by
Raven now one by one dicks former
teammates would follow Barbara and voice
their encouragement and their belief in
him and hearing the voices of those that
he's closest to Barbara Starfire Tim
Drake Damian and Bruce dick is able to
muster all that he can and joins the
collective attempt to force the Phoenix
out now as dick begins to make progress
in reclaiming his body Superman and
other heroes stopped fighting him not
wanting to enter him further and so in
an epic struggle the collective power of
all the psyches of dick and his allies
forces the Phoenix entity from his mind
and Raven banishes it from the main DC
reality to an alternate dimension the
battle however has left dick physically
broken and mentally exhausted and so in
the coming weeks as dicks body heals he
works with Raven to restore his mind as
well and it appears that his mind is
made whole once again fully embracing
the identities of Dick Grayson and
Nightwing once more and so this story
would accomplish a couple of things
first it restores Nightwing's character
to the fan-favorite version that had
been missing for too long in DC Comics
and basically removes all the regrets
and stuff which nobody liked anyway
right nobody would care if that what's
gone secondly and introduces a new
threat to the DC Universe in the form of
the Phoenix force that would definitely
break through the dimensional barrier
shutting it off from the DC Universe and
threaten all of existence once more when
it bonds itself to superboy-prime
we're gonna make that story
superboy-prime becomes the Dark Phoenix
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]